Dewa, dainika no kanji no shoukai wo shimasu.
Dainika de wa korera no jyuuroku no kanji
wo shoukai shimasu.
Mazu, saishou no kanji, ee kono kanji nandesukeredo
mo, ee imi wa compare no imi ga arimasu.
So you can imagine like two people sitting
and comparing to each other.
So kore compare desu.
De, eeto yomikata nan desu keredomo, omyomi,
kore wa hi.
Ee tatoeba, hikaku suru, to compare.
De ma, iroiro na iikata ga arun desukeredo
mo, tatoeba, A to B wo hikaku suru, to compare
A and B. Mochiron a wo b to hikaku suru, compare
A with B koto wo tsukatte kudasai.
Tatoeba desu ne, ma amerika (America) to nihon
wo hikaku suru to, bunkateki ni iroiro na
chigai ga arimasu.
Ma konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara, kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo,
kore wa, kura, kuraberu.
Kore mo imi wa to compare desu.
Ee desukara, amerika (America) to nihon wo
kuraberuto, ee sou desu ne,
tabemono ga zenzen chigaimasu to ka,
iroiro na bunshou ga daijoubu desu.
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa ee, substitute,
sorekara generation, charge,
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee, kono hidari gawa no radical, kore wa mo
minna yoku shitteiru, kore wa person.
Sorekara, kono migi gawa, kono paato (part)
nan desu keredomo, imi wa spears.
So a person with spears, it’s a guard and
a guard needs to be shifted or changing shift.
De, together, ma, substitute sonna imi ga
dedekimasu.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de dai
toka tai to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Yoku tsukawareru no wa jidai.
Tatoeba, ima nihon wa reiwa jidai desu, era
no imi desu.
Sorekara gendai, modern times.
Sedai, generation.
Ato desu ne, juudai, nijyuudai, sanjuudai
to iu, ano nantsuka, teeanagers, twenties,
thirties, sonna tsukaikata mo shimasu.
De, nanajyuu nendai, nendai tte iu to, ma
seventies, eighties, hachijyuu nendai, konna
tsukaikata mo shimasu.
Sorekara desu ne, sono, charge to iu imi de
de, imi de desu ne.
Tatoeba denki dai, denki no okane to iu.
Sorekara, denwa dai, denwa no tame no okane.
Sorekara bus dai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ato, eeto, doushite daihyou suru, to represent.
Ee, sorekara, koutai suru.
Kore wa to take turns no imi ga arimasu.
Kunyomi nan desu keredomo, ma kunyomi wa omoni
kono ka koredake de daijyoubu da to omoimasu.
Kawaru, to take the place of.
Yoku tsukawareru pattern toshite wa, nani
nani ni kawatte.
Tatoeba, tanaka sensei ni kawatte, kono jyugyou
wo okonaimasu.
In place of tanaka sensei.
Ee, sorekara, tanaka sensei no kawari ni.
Kore mo yoku tsuwaremasu, tanaka sensei no
kawari ni, kono jyugyou wo okonaimasu.
Ma, kore, imi wa dochidemo onaji imi desu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa without
failure, surely no imi ga arimasu.
De, mo minna kono paato (part), kore wa daijoubu
desu yo ne, kore wa heart no imi ga arimasu.
So there’s a person who has a secret in
his heart.
He surely keeps it.
He without failure keeps this secret to iu
no de, without failure, or surely to iu imi desu.
De, eeto onyomi nan
desu keredomo, hitsu to iu yomikata desu.
Tatoeba, hitsuyou na kore na adjective desu.
Hitsuyouna mono wa pasupooto (passport) dake
desu.
Sorekara desu ne, yoku tsukawareru pattern
nandesu keredomo, nani nani suru hitsuyou
ga arimasu.
Regularly there exists a necessity nandesu
keredomo, tatoeba, nihon ni iku mae ni, pasupooto
(passport) wo toru hitsuyou ga arimasu.
Ma shizen na, natural english should be you
need to get the passport.
So, konna pattern wo yoku tsukaimasu.
Ato, hisshi.
Kore wa desperate nan desu keredomo, hisshi
ni, ee, kore adverbial na tsukaikata de, hisshi
ni benkyou shiteimasu.
Ee sorekara, hitsudokusho.
Kore wa wakaru deshouka, kore yomu, ee kore
wa hon to iu imi nan desu keredomo, a must
read book to iu imi desu.
Ee, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, kore wa kanarazu.
Ee, tatoeba, ee without fail nan desu ga,
asu no juugyou wa kanarazu kite kudasai.
Kono shikudai wa asumade ni kanarazu dashite
kudasai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Hai. Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji nan desu keredomo, imi wa reason
no imi desu.
Ee minna ma kono kanji wa shittemasu yo ne,
tanaka san no ta, ma rice field toka, field
no imi nan desu keredomo, so there is a stick
in the field, there got to be some reason
for that.
Tte iu no de, reason nan desu keredomo, ee
onyomi dewa yu, yuu toka, yui to iu ee yomikata
ga arun desu keredomo, tatoeba jiyuu desu
yo ne, kore wa freedom.
Sorekara, riyuu, reason.
Ato, ee, keiyuusuru, to iu no de, go via,
yoku hikouki no hanashi wo suru toki ni desu ne.
Kono hikouki wa arasuka (Alaska) keiyuu desu,
via Alaska to iu.
Konna tsukaikata wo shima.
Kunyomi de yoshi, to iu no wa arun desu keredomo,
hito no namae toka yoku tsukawarerun desu
ga, ma, eeto, kono ressun (lesson) de wa kunyomi
kankei nai to omoimasu no de, benkyou shinakutemo
daijoubu desu.
Hai, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa combine,
sorekara fit, match no imi ga arimasu.
Tatoeba desu ne, you can imagine a big pot,
and then this is the lid part so the lid and
the pot have to match, or fit to each other.
Konna kanji desu.
De, eeto yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi
de wa gou toka, ka, sorekara, ga to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
Ee, tatoeba, goukei suru.
Kore wa to add up.
Yoku tsukwareru no wa, goukei de ichiman yen
desu.
In total to iu imi deshou ka.
Sorekara, goui suru, kore wa, to agree.
Nani nani ni goui suru.
Ee, tatoeba, kanojo no teian, teian ma suggestion
nan desu keredomo, kanojo no teian ni goui
shimasu.
Sorekara, shuugo suru.
Kore wa intransitive desu.
Nani nani ga shuugou suru.
Tatoeba, gakusei ga shuugou suru.
Ashita wa gozen shichiji ni shuugou shitekudasai.
Sorekara, tsugou to iu, tsugou ga ii, tsugou
ga warui, ee convenient, sorekara inconvenient
nan desu keredomo, konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara, amerika (America) gasshuukoku, United
States e no toki ni, kono shuu to iu no wa
state, state desu.
So iroiro na shu ga gather, add up.
Soshite, United States to iu amerika (America)
gasshuukoku to iu kuni no namae ni natte imasu.
Ato, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, au.
De, kokode desu ne, yoku tsukawareru no wa
au nan desu keredomo, eeto, verb stem, hoka
no verb to au to iu no de, do something to
each other no iu formation, e function ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, tasuke au, kore wa, eeto, tasukeru
no stem form desu keredomo, to help each other.
Hanashi au, talk to each other.
Soudanshi au, to consult to each other.
Konna tsukaikata wo yoku shimasu.
Sorekara, eeto, independent ni, awaseru, to
put together.
Sorekara, kore wa noun nan desu keredomo,
shiriai, acquaintance desu ne.
Tomodachi to chotto chigaimasu keredo mo,
ee chotto shita shiriai desu.
Sorekara, shiai, kore wa game.
Ee, sorekara match, ano, sports no shiai,
tennis no shiai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji no imi desu keredomo, kore
busy to iu imi desu.
De, ee, hidari gawa no kono radical, ee, kono
radical no imi wa heart no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, soshite, kono migi gawa, kore, die, shibou,
aruiwa nakunaru, to pass away, kou itta kotoba
ga arun desu keredomo, so a busy person might
die with a heart attack.
Ma, konna kanji de oboete mite kudasai.
Sorekara, onyomi nan desu keredomo, kore wa
bou, tabou na.
Kore wa, ma totemo isogashii to iu imi nan
desu keredomo.
Tabou na sarariiman (salaryman) seikatsu.
Kunyomi, isogashii.
Kore ichiban yoku tsukawareru to omoun desu
keredomo, ee, isogashii.
Tanaka san wa itsumo isogashisou desu.
Sorekara, busy with tte iu no itai toki ni
wa.
Tatoeba, tanaka-san wa kaigi no jyunbi de
isogashii desu.
De wo tsukatte kudasai.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa real,
fruit, nut no imi ga arimasu.
De, mo kono ue no top paato (part), minna
mo yoku shitteimasu ne, a roof of the house.
Soshite, there is some sort of like a fruit
tree inside the house and koko no naka nandesu
keredomo, kore wa san bon desu.
Kono kanji, kore wa oto, husband to iu imi
nan desu ga, kore ja arimasen.
Koko line mitsu ga arimasu kara kiotsukete
kudasai.
Soshite, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi
de jitsu.
Tatoeba, jitsu wa, as a matter of fact, jitsu
ryoku, real ability desu yo ne, kore wa power
to iu imi de, real power, real ability.
Sorekara, jijitsu, fact.
Kakujistsu na, certain.
Sorekara jitsugen suru, to realize something.
Sorekara jikken suru, to experiment.
Ato desu ne, amari tsukawanaii desukeredo
mo, kinomi, kore wa nut.
Sorekara, minoru, to bear fruit to iu tsukaikata
ga arimasu.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa nature,
sorekara sex, gender, sorekara ano tatoeba
probability toka, kono -ity, kore wa tsukuru
suffix no imi mo arimasu.
De, paato (part) nan desu keredomo, kore daijoubu
desu ne, kochira no paato (part), kore wa
heart.
Sorekara, kore wa umareru, is born.
So heart is born with nature, sex, gender
to iu imi desu.
De, eeto yomikata nan desu keredomo, kunyomi
wa arimasen.
Onyomi dake desu.
De, sei toka shou to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba seikaku, kore personality.
Seishitsu, kore ma, nature, sorekara disposition.
Seinou, kore wa ability desu ne.
Sorekara, seibetsu, kore wa gender.
Sorekara, kosei, individuality.
Sorekara sakki itta sono suffix nandesu keredomo,
ningensei to iu no de, tatoeba,
ningen tte iu no wa human nan desu keredomo,
ee ningensei to iu to humanity.
Ee sorekara, kanousei, potentiality to iu -ity,
kore wo tsukuru nandesuka function mo arimasu.
Ato, honshou, true nature.
Hontou no nature to iu no de, true nature
to iu tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Hai. Dewa, tsugi no kanji wo mite mimasu.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa express,
surface, table to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, kono ue no paato (part) nan desu yo ne,
kore looks like master, shujin no shu nan
desu keredomo, sorekara shita no paato (part),
kore wa looks like clothes.
So a
master is wearing special clothes to express
his authority to iu no de, together, express
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata desu keredomo, onyomi de hyou.
Tatoeba, hyou kore table toka, chart.
Ronbun naka de, hyou ichi, table one toka
to iu tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Sorekara hyoujou, facial expression, hyoumen,
kore wa surface desu yo ne.
Tatoeba, tsukue no hyoumen toka, nandesuka.
Ike no hyoumen toka sonna tsukaikata ga daijoubu
desu.
Sorekara, yotei hyou, kore yotei to iu no
wa plan, so yotei no table to iu no desu, schedule.
Hyougen suru, to express.
Daihyousuru, to represent.
Sorekara, happyou suru.
Tatoeba ronbun wo happyou shimasu, to present
no imi desu.
Kunyomi no hou desu keredomo, mazu omote,
kore wa surface nan desu keredomo, front side
no surface desu.
Tatoeba, kono coin no omote.
Sono hantai ga ura to iimasu.
Ato, nani nani wo arawasu, transitive form,
transitive verb desu keredomo, tatoeba, motto
kimochi wo arawa shita hou ga ii desu.
Sorekara, nani nani ga arawareru, kore wa
intransitive nan desu keredomo, ma kanjou
ga yoku arawarete imasu.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ja, tsugi  no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa yesterday
toka last no imi ga arimasu.
De, mazu hidari gawa, kore wa, ano hi, ano,
day to iu imi desu.
Ee sorekara kore migi gawa nan desu keredomo,
ee, kono tsukuru to make, ano, kono kochira
gawa to onaji desu.
De, ma amari omoshirokunai hanashi kamo shirenain
desu keredomo, the day it was made already,
so it’s yesterday, last to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, ano onyomi de
saku to iu yomikata desu.
Ee, tatoeba, sakuya, last night.
Sakuban, kore mo last night desu.
Sorekara kore kinou no hi to iu no de, sakujitsu.
Tokidoki hito ni yotte wa kore wo kinou to
tokubetsu ni yomu hito mo imasu.
Sorekara kore desukeredo mo, issaku jitsu,
koremo desu ne, ano hito ni yotte, kore wo
ototoi to yomu hito mo imasu.
Sorekara kore sakunen, kore wa last year.
Kiotsukete kudasai ne, kono last year no toki
ni wa, saku nen de daijoubu nandesukeredo
mo, last month no toki ni wa sengetsu.
Sorekara last week no toki ni wa senshuu.
Ee kono eeto prefix ga chigaimasu no de kiotsukete
kudasai.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa mutual,
phase, sorekara minister no imi mo arimasu.
De kono hidari gawa, ii desu ne, kore wa tree
desu yo ne.
Sorekara migi gawa kore wa eyes nan desu keredomo,
imagine that there are you know two peoples
eyes are behind the tree and that they are
mutually checking with each other to iu, sono
mutual to iu imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
sou toka shou to iu no ga arimasu.
Ee, tatoeba yoku tsukau no ga soudan suru,
to consult.
De, ano particle nan desu keredomo, kore sensei
ni soudan suru, soudanshita.
Sorekara, sensei to soudanshita.
Dochira mo iin desu keredomo, ano, to wo tsukau
to mou shukoshi sono together, with no imi
ga dedekimasu.
Demo sensei ni tte iu to, mou sukoshi sono
direction desu yo ne, to tte iu.
Sonna imi ga dedekimasu.
Sorekara, sougo kankei, kore wa mutual relationship.
Sorekara, soushisouai, chotto muzukashii kotoba
kamo shirenai desu keredomo, kono sou tte
iu no wa mutual desu yo ne.
So mutual ni omotte, mutual ni love.
So soushisouai means mutual love.
Sorekara, souzoku suru, to inherit.
Soshite, sono minister no imi toshite, shushou,
prime minister to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Tsugi ni, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, kore
wa ai.
Aishou, kore mutual no nature.
So to iu koto de compatibility to iu imi desu.
Yoku iu no wa ano hito to wa aishou ga ii,
aishou ga warui, I'm
compatible with that person.
Sonna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sorekara, aite, partner.
Sorekara, aikawarazu, as usual.
Ikaga desu ka?
Ee aikawarazu desu yo, as usual yoku ano nihonjin
no hito ga aisatsu de tsukaimasu.
Ee dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa important,
summarize, sorekara require no imi ga arimasu.
De kono ue no paato (part) nan desu keredomo,
kore imi toshite wa to cover no imi ga arimasu.
Shita wa onna hito no onna desu yo ne.
So some culture requires women to cover her
face to iu no de, require, aruiwa important
to iu imi wa dedekimasu.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de wa
you to iu yomikata desu.
Ee, tatoeba, hitsuyou na, ee necessary.
Ee, kore, mae ni mo yarimashita kedo, nani
nani suru, yo ku tsukawareru no ga nani nani
suru hitsuyou ga aru.
There exists a necessity to do such and such.
Tatoeba, nihon ni iku mae ni paspooto (passport)
wo toru hitsuyou ga aru.
Sorekara, fuyou na.
Kore, kore wa negative no prefix desu kara,
unnecessary.
Juuyou na, important.
Sorekara youkyuu suru, to demand.
Soshite, youyaku suru, korede to summarize
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Tsugi ni kunyomi nan desu keredomo, minna
wa kono i dake wo ano nandesuka benkyou sureba
ii kato to omoimasu.
Kore de iru to iimasu.
Ikooru (equal) hitsuyou desu to iu imi desu.
To need.
De eeto nihon ni iku tame ni wa visa ga iru.
It requires toka, it’s necessary to have
a visa.
Hitsuyou desu to onaji imi desu.
Sono party ni iku tame ni wa tokubetsu na
shoutaijou, invitation, ga iru.
Sou iu imi desu.
De tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa evening
to iu imi desu.
Do, hidari gawa no kono paato (part) desu
ne, kore wa sun.
Soshite kono migi gawa desu keredomo, kore
escape to iu imi ga arimasu.
So sun is escaping so it becomes evening,
evening to iu imi desu.
De eeto yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi
de ban.
Tatoeba, konban, this evening.
Myouban, kore wa ashita no ban, tomorrow evening.
Sorekara, sakuban, kore wa kinou no ban.
Sorekara maiban, kore wa mainichi no ban to
iu no de, every evening.
Sorekara bangohan.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Kunyomi wa arimasen.
Hai dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa short no
imi ga arimasu.
De, kono hidari gawa nan desu keredomo, kore
wa arrows.
Sorekara migi gawa kore wa bean desu.
So an arrow hit the target, the very small
bean so it must be a short distance,
to iu no de, short to iu imi desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo , tan to iu yomikata
desu, onyomi.
Tanki na, quick tempered.
Ano hito wa totemo tanki na hito desu ne,
toka desu yo ne.
Sorekara, tankikan, kore wa mijikai kikan,
short period.
Hantai wa choukikan.
Sorekara, tansho, korede weak point to iu
imi ni narimasu.
Kono hantai wa chousho, ii tokoro to iu imi
desu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ee kore
wa mijikai, minna shitteimasu yo ne, mijikai, short.
Sorekara, sono hantai wa nagai.
Konna tsukaikata desu.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu, kono kanji desukerdo
mo, imi wa sense, sorekara feel no imi ga
arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite ikimashou.
Mazu, kono component, kono, eeto chotto
chigau desu keredomo, ma, ano imi toshite
wa kore, inu, Chinese zodiac no imi desu.
Sorekara kore, kono paato (part) desu ne,
kore mouth.
Sorekara, ichiban shita no tokoro, kore wa
heart.
So, a dog can express their sense of feeling
with their mouths tte iu, ma,
konna oboekata de daijoubu ka to omoimasu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de kan
to iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kanjiru, to feel.
Sorekara, kandou suru, kore, to be deeply
moved.
Ano, particle ni kiotsukete kudasai, nani
nani ni kandou suru.
Tatoeba, kanojou no yasashisa ni kandou shita.
Sorekara, kansha suru, kore wa to appreciate,
to be thankful nandesu ga, ee tatoeba, nihongo
no sensei ni kanshashite imasu.
Kore mo particle no ni desu.
Sorekara, kanshin suru, kore wa to be impressed
with something nan desu ga.
Ee, tatoeba, ano gakusei no majimesa ni wa,
majimesa ni wa kanshin shite imasu.
Sono seriousness.
Diligence desu yo ne.
Kore mo particle wa ni desu.
Sorekara desu ne, eeto meishi, noun, de iroiro
na mono ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kankaku, sense, sensation.
Kanjou, feeling.
Kansou, kore wa impression toka, thought nan
desu ga, yoku sumimasen kansou kikasete kudasai.
Give me or, let me hear your impression toka,
sonna iikata desu.
Sorekara, sekininkan, kore wa responsibility.
Yoku tsukau no wa kanojo wa sekininkan ga
tsuyoi hito desu.
Sorekara, binkan na, kore wa sensitive.
Sono hantai ga donkan na, insensitive nan
desu keredomo.
Ee, kanojo wa binkan na, dochira mo kore na
adjective desu kedo, binkan na hito da.
Sorekara kare wa donkan na hito da.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Dewa, ressun (lesson) ni no saigo no kanji
desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa difficult,
sorekara disaster to iu imi desu.
De, kono hidari gawa kono ano paato (part)
desu keredomo, kore wa kanji no kan, kochira
no paato (part) to onaji desu.
Sorekara, kono migi gawa, kono paato (part)
wa desu ne, bird to iu imi wo shimasu.
Ma, Chinese, sorekara bird to iu, ma nandesuka,
combination desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de nan
to iimasu.
Tatoeba, nanmon.
Kore wa muzukashii mondai, ma, difficult question.
Ee, sorekara, sainan, kore wa misfortune.
Yoku sore wa sainan deshita nee, it was a
misfortune toka, sonna iikata wo shimasu.
Ato, kon nan na, difficult.
Sorekara, kore kiotsukete kudasai, kochira
no kanji no toki mo, sorekara kochira no kanji
mo dochira mo hinansuru nandesukeredo mo,
saishou no hou, kore wa escape no imi ga arimasu.
So, kono hinansuru, kore wa to take refugee,
nani nani kara hinanshimashita.
Demo, kochira wa to blame imi desu.
Dare dare wo nani nani wo hinansuru.
Ee tatoeba, kare no shippai wo hinanshite
wa ikenai, don’t blame his failure to iu imi desu.
Kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, ichiban
yoku tsukawareru no wa kono muzukashii
desu yo ne.
Sorekara desu ne, eeto doushi no stem, ee,
plus kore de gatai to iu desu keredomo, ee,
wasuregatai, difficult to forget.
Sorekara, rikai shigatai, difficult to understand.
Konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.